chers amis nous apprécions très haut le
fait que vous soyez aujourd'hui avec
nous à l'ag de décisions importantes qui
vont être prises pour toute l'europe je
suis très sincèrement reconnaissants à
vous tous pour avoir commencer votre
séjour en ukraine par la visite de la
ville des dates ligne pour constater de
visu sur place ce que les envahisseurs
russe en fait en perpétrait face aux
populations et aux villes craignent un
renouvellement napolitano entretien que
nous allons puisque nous venons d'avoir
on montrait je crois que notre plus
grande force c'est l'union l'union dont
dépendent tout le reste
lorsque vous était déjà à la gare de
kiev une alerte aérienne ont retenti
comme nous savions d'être le cas à
nouveau tout à l'heure
tout le cren vie dans ces conditions ce
qui prouve une fois de plus que la
russie n'est pas très
choisis pas à quel moment
faire le cadeau de la sécurité dans
toute l'europe l'agression russe contre
le crains c'est une agression contre
l'ensemble de l'europe contre une europe
unie contre chacun d'entre nous contre
ces les valeurs que nous avons en
partage et notre réponse unique est la
seule possible face à cela le crains se
trouve à l'avant garde aujourd'hui de
cette lutte contre l'agression russe et
mais il n'est pas seul un autre format
d'aujourd'hui le confirme nous avons
échangé dans une parfaite compréhension
entre nous donc de la nécessité de
renforcer les capacités de défense de
l'ukraine je remercie à tous les
partenaires pour les décisions qui vient
d'être actée nous avons parlé d'une
approche coordonnée pour soutenir le
cren sur le plan économique
à la fois l'état et ses populations
cepsa population à nous avons envisagé
la reconstruction de l'après-guerre
notre action commune pour prévenir la
crise alimentaire fomenté par la
fédération de russie nous avons nous à
nous devons faire tout notre possible
pour prévenir ce complot contre le monde
entier qui a pour but de ce mail car
hausse dans les pays d'afrique et d'asie
à cause des pénuries alimentaires
nous avons parlé de l'accroissement de
cette pression contre la russie qui nous
doit aller par les sanctions nous avons
évoqué aussi la perspective européenne à
l'intégration européenne de notre pays
je vous informe est effectivement de la
situation sur les différents fronts de
la défense menée par les forces armées
dans le dos de basse autour de kharkiv
dans le sud d'ailleurs je vous informais
des frappes par missile que le crâne
subit chaque jour j'ai parlé delà de la
quantité des missiles qui ont visé les
populations ukrainien rien que pour ce
mois il ne s'agit que de 3000 s'il
s'agit de 3000 la plupart d'entre eux
visent des infrastructures
que nous avions en matière de défense
vivement tous mes partenaires d'apporter
leur aide en la matière pour tous les
fournitures d'armes lourds et dont nous
avons toujours besoin pour le système
lance missiles et systèmes de missile
antiaérien il s'agit là de la défense
des vie des ukrainiens chaque jour de
retard pour acheminer cela donc à son
coût en termes de vies humaines et en
termes de destruction que se disent nos
villes
donc le cren reste dépendante et plus
vite ces fournitures vont se faire plus
fort sera notre capacité de défense qui
ce que l'ensemble de la population un
grand l'ukrainien n'entend qu'une chose
c'est la grèce la libération totale du
territoire de notre pays j'ai
évoqué donc les différents efforts qui
sont entrepris par tous les partenaires
pour rétablir la paix nous constatons
l'absence du côté russe de la bonne
volonté pour relancer ce processus de
paix la russie ne souhaite pas la paix
elle ne souhaite qu'une chose c'est la
guerre en ce moment même où je vous
parle donc au palais marie au centre
ville de kiev les troupes russes
poursuivent leur offensive dans le dos
de basse et elles sont se retranche dans
le sud le pays agresseur doit
comprendre une chose
elle n'a pas d'alternative
cela serait la solution pacifique est
possible elle doit se mettre à
rechercher cet hiver mais de la voie
vers 7 vers cette solution en
loin de ça la russie poursuit ses
tentatives à gagner encore plus de
terrain ukrainien et ce n'est pas
acceptable
son objectif est de casser l'ukraine et
par la casse et toute l'ukraine toute
l'europe tout l'unité
européenne elle cherche à démontrer que
le cren n'est pas consistante et en même
temps les valeurs européennes ne peuvent
pas défendre les pays qui aspirent donc
nous allons nous devons casser tous
ensemble ce scénario
est pour ça notre unité
condition indispensable
un gage de cette position commune
pourrait venir part à un pas en avant
sur la voie de l'intégration de
l'ukraine au sein de l'union européenne
donc
le statut de candidat à l'adhésion pour
le cren est une chance historique de
renforcer la stabilité européenne est
peut être une des plus grandes décisions
de cette première moitié du xxième
siècle j'espère que cette décision
commune sera la nôtre est la plus forte
que nous pouvons adopter
il s'agit en parlant de cette
intégration dans l'ombre chemin mais
nous devons tous ensemble faire le
premier pas sur ce chemin et notre pays
est prête à faire tout le nécessaire
pour devenir membre la plains titre de
l'union européenne et toutes les
populations tout le peuple ukrainien ils
aspirent
nous avons vu les sondages qui montrent
que la plupart la majorité des
populations européennes soutient cette
perspective d'intégration européenne
delecray nous avons un niveau
historique de soutien
donc en faveur de l'ukraine et de son
peuple et c'est la chance saisir nous
avons évoqué les sanctions qui sont
adoptées par l'union européenne en vue
de rétablir la paix le septième paquet
de sanctions doit être donc agréés et
adopté est un autre sujet qui nous
intéressait effectivement c'est tout le
travail que nous devons faire après la
guerre pour reconstruire le pays
et pour faire payer la russie tout tous
les dommages causés temps dans cette
guerre à tout toutes les populations à
toutes les entreprises toutes les villes
de l'ukraine le travail continue en ce
sens nous avons envisagé l'ensemble les
possibilités de prévenir une crise les
ventes globales
l'ukraine est prête donc envisager des
solutions pour
casser le blocus des ports ukrainiens
mais c'est surtout celui qui a donc à
l'origine de ce blocus c'est à dire la
fédération de russie qui doit faire le
nécessaire nous remercions pour tout ce
qui a été fait pour organiser le transit
des marchandises ukrainiens par les
différentes voies terrestres fluviales
et autres donc je considère votre visite
ici comme la visite des amis donc et qui
va être historique avoir une
signification historique
je vous remercie pour tous ces échanges
préparons-nous ensemble à ces décisions
importantes qui arrivent enfin afin de
consolider la sécurité de toute l'europe
merci encore de votre présence ici